سحبت قوات الشرطه من محيط منزل رئيس
الوزراء السابق عمران خان بعد الشباكات مع
انصاره وفق قناه جيو ال باكستانيه
وبحسب الشرطه فقد تم ايقاف عمليه الاعتقال
بسبب مباراه كبيره للعبه
هذا وتجمع المئات من انصار خان امام منزله
بعد وصول فريق من الشرطه من اسلام اباد
لاعتقاله بناء على امر قضائي ووفق مصادر
طبيه اصيب 54 شرطيا وثمانيه مواطنين في
الاشتباكات الجاريه منذ الثلاثاء
رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني السابق عمران خان
قال ان الحكومه تريده وراء القضبان لمنعه
من المشاركه في الانتخابات وقال خالي
وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه ان مذكره الاعتقال
الصادره ضده ليست بسبب خرقه لاي قانون لكن
الحكومه تريد حبسه حتى يتم منعه من دخول
الانتخابات المقرره في وقت لاحق من هذا
العام
[تصفيق]
اهلا وسهلا بك هل فعلا السلطات
الباكستانيه مصممه تماما على اعتقال عمران
خان ام لا كل ما يجري عبد الرحمن مجرد ضغط
سياسي على عمران خاليه وقف حملاته
الاعلاميه ضد الحكومه
نعم الحكومه الباكستانيه نفت صلتها
بالقضايا المرفوعه ضد عمران خان ومذكرات
التوقيف بحقه وزيره الاعلام الباكستانيه
مريم اورنج اكدت بان القضايا المرفوعه ضد
عمران خان هي قضايا جنائيه بحته ولا دخل
للحكومه فيها وعلى عمران خان الالتزام بما
تمليه عليه المحاكم وما تامره به
المحاكم وقضاتها
اود الاشاره هنا الى ان الاوضاع هنا في
مدينه لاهور بدات تعود الى الهدوء النسبي
بعد نحو 24 من المناوشات المتقطعه بين
قوات الامن وانصار رئيس الوزراء السابق
عمران خان كان هناك قرار من قاضي في محكمه
لاهور العليا امر قوات الشرطه بوصف
تنفيذ الاجراءات المتعلقه بمذكره الاعتقال
الصادره بحق رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني
عمران خان حتى صباح يوم غد الخميس ايضا
كان هناك التماس قدمه الفريق القانوني
لامران خان امام محكمه لاهور العليا وايضا
امام المحكمه اسباب العليا هناك عده
التماسات لتوقيف العمل بمذكرات الاعتقال
بل والغائها وايضا الغاء بعض القضايا
المرفوعه بالضعف عمران خان يعتبر ان
القضايا المرفوعه ضده قضايا
ويؤكد انه لم يخالف القانون عبد الرحمن في
حال تم اعتقاله ما الذي قد يقوم به انصاره
والذي تخشاه الحكومه يعني اي ردود فعل
يمكن توقعها
الساعات المقبله او ربما يوم غد سوف يحسم
مساله اعتقال عمران خان من من عدمه عمران
خان او الفريق القانوني العمران خان قدم
تعهدا لمحكمه السماوات العليا بانه سوف
يحضر جلسه يوم السبت المقبل ايضا قدم
التماسا لالغاء مذكره التوقيف لكن قاضي
محكمه الشباب العليا لم يقبل هذا الانكلاس
لكن احال مساله قبول تعهده بالمسؤول امام
المحكمه الجنائيه الى المحكمه الجنائيه
نفسها التي ستحدد ان كانت سوف تقبل
بالتعهد الذي قضاه عمران خان للمثول
امامها يوم السبت المقبل وعلى هذا ربما
يوم غد هو سيكون حاسما بما اذا سوف تواصل
الشرطه او
ستقوم باعتقار رئيس وزراء السابق ام سيكون
هناك راي مغاير لقاضي المحكمه الجنائيه
ربما بتوقيف مذكره الاعتقال بحقه لكن فيما
لو تم اعتقال عمران خان فهو قد حذر من انه
بات يفقد السيطره على انصاره وحذر من ان
ما تقوم ما قال انها ما تقوم به الحكومه
يجر البلاد الفوضى والهدف من ذلك هو
تاجيل موعد الانتخابات هنا في اقليم
البنجاب والذي من المقرر ان يكون بتاريخ
الثلاثين من ابريل المقبل من لاهور شرق
باكستان مراسل العربيه عبد الرحمن المزيني
شكرا جزيلا لك عبد الرحمن على هذه
المتابعه